Ilia battle angel is the latest manga
goes movie film directed by Robert
Rodriguez similar to the source material
there's a lot to unpack from the film
and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about a liter and the ending
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you want to go into the film
with fresh eyes then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to the film is set in the Year 2563
and follows a liter a cyborg that houses
a fully intact human brain Aleta suffers
from amnesia but after being discovered
by a doctor named Dyson Hyde oh she
slowly begins to piece together her past
Aleta discovers that Idol is a
hunter-warrior and follows in his
footsteps registering as one even though
he dissuade her against it this sets her
off on a journey to become a champion
motor baller which is a competitive
sport within the land throughout the
movie she battles it out and try out
races adjusts to a new body and grows in
several ways this is very much a
coming-of-age story that leaves one
lingering plot thread for what direction
and the franchise could go to in the
future sprinkled throughout the film are
hints of a mysterious character and
named Nova Nova is a white-haired
goggled man that speaks through the
people of iron City after possessing
them Nova is a master manipulator
throughout the film due to his ability
to assume others but his identity is a
closely guarded secret by the film's
close after everything Aleta has been
through she finally becomes a star moto
Ball athlete and we see nobre looking
over her it's at this point that we
discover that the character is actually
played by none other than Edward Norton
whilst the film leaves his roles and
intentions ambiguous there are several
things that we can take from this
appearance from looking at the source
material
obviously you don't cast an actor like
Ed Norton unless you have big plans for
him so it's pretty safe to say that he
will be playing a big part in the next
film that should it be made Nova is a
genius with a huge intellect that
specializes in nanotechnology and this
leads him to participate in many
humane science experiments he becomes a
massive antagonist that throws many
roadblocks in front of alia but
ultimately he is completely fascinated
by her he really pushes her to her
limits and often seems like he will kill
her but due to her abilities she is able
to survive Aleta eventually ends up
apparently killing Nova at location
known as the granite in which Nova
manages to transform into a cyberspace
landscape in which he possesses the
abilities of a god while she decapitate
him he eventually returns kills Aleta
and then reconstructs her and this leads
to another huge faceoff in which the
villain ends up creating multiple
versions of himself it's a really
fascinating read and if you enjoyed the
film that I highly suggest that you seek
out the source material as due to a poor
box office it's unlikely that we will
get a sequel the film adaptation is
faithful enough that it won't feel too
jarring picking up the boobs and it's
definitely worth checking out if you're
interested in the movie obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the film
and what direction you think that the
sequel will head in if we ever get one
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of this week's other big movie
the lego movie to the second part which
will be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]